sylvain n'guessan bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
laurent gbagbo mais aussi charles blé
goudé vont donc récupérer leurs
passeports ils vont pouvoir quitter
bruxelles et la haye pourquoi la cour
pénale internationale a décidé de lever
une partie des restrictions qui leur
était imposée merci ça va que depuis
janvier 2009 que le président laurent
gbagbo a été acquitté au moment où il a
appris à le recevoir en grande forme
enfin pousser tiède et ses partisans il
ya eu l'appel de la procureure de
l'impéritie da et depuis a réagi avec la
banda dans la vie riche
la dernière date posté le 27 mai il y
avait une date ultérieure et hier avec
une grande joie que cet artisan appris
que la cpi lui à bordères la liberté de
mouvement à 106,2 certaines
conditionnalités
je pense que la juge de la cpi auquel
mois étudié le dossier ils ont vu que je
n'ai pas grande chose allait
prochainement mamour qui pourrait
baisser de 7 à liberté de mouvement a
songé des conditionnalités tous sont
fixés alors est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est une nouvelle victoire pour l'ex
président ivoirien et son co accusé
bien sûr c'est une victoire pour
l'honneur norbourg pour un passionné de
la commune monsieur charles ble goude
éviter des mouvements à quatre 4 mois
avant la présidentielle que c'est une
victoire
je pense que depuis janvier 2010 n'a
jusqu'à aujourd'hui pratiquement 18 mois
que le dossier traîne savates présents
laurent gbagbo bénéficie des libertés
nous voir qu'à voir les élections
c'est une grande victoire pour la mise
en lambeaux pour les chars de bouder
aussi
famille politique néanmoins laurent
gbagbo signé et charles blé goudé n'en
ont pas fini pour autant avec la justice
internationale
à quel avenir judiciaire faut-il
s'attendre pour les deux hommes je pense
que l'essentiel a déjà été fait à
lamballe sud elle a eu du temps pour
régler toutes les preuves de sorte à ce
que de leurs ébats moussa condamné à se
lever négociable que ça condamné sur la
glace parce que n'a pas encore plus
aurélie l'épreuve et comme je le disais
tantôt en côte d'ivoire il ya les sur
présidentielle en octobre 2020 savons
que le président gbagbo peut se baser
pollution que les autorités du pays
d'accueil à cette servante comme celle
initiale de vous déplacer déplacés je
crois que l'essentiel est fait je ne
vois pas d'un incident aurait pu
demander tout cet exemple durant qui est
apparu pour en discuter
alors tout pays dans lequel laurent
gbagbo souhaitera se rendre doit
notamment on le disait accepter au
préalable de le recevoir ce qui rend
incertain finalement son éventuel retour
en côte d'ivoire comment les choses
pourraient se passer pour son parti le
front populaire ivoirien qui se prépare
vous disiez à l'élection présidentielle
d'octobre la baule d'atik 12 la
constitution stipule qu' aucun ivoirien
les métros de à l'exil si on veut
respecter la constitution de berlin
babeau et le blé goudé ne peut pas être
contraints à l'exil d'un de pétition
demandant le renvoi du bois développée
bien sûr il ya eu le procès à 9 heures
de cuisine heure où j'étais condamné à
20 ans de prison
à quatre mois de la présidentielle à mon
avis le pouvoir d'abidjan gagnera
privilégier la recherche du compromis
donc la solution politique de sorte à
éviter que la rue les perles du service
où ce genre de questions pour rappel
monsieur alassane ouattara président de
la côte d'ivoire a été candidat elle est
sûre les airs 2010 afin qu'on peut plus
pratiquer sous la houlette du président
sud africain de cette amende mais qui
peut être que certains le président
ouattara de son retour de l'ascenseur
pour que la solution politique et cory
politique us dans board s ils veulent
tous systématique au doigt et quelle est
l'opinion de la population ivoirienne
sur un retour éventuel de l'ex président
laurent gbagbo pour l'appréciation
aseptisé où les partisans de son camp
c'est une gare dubai j'espère le voir et
je vous ramène est bien évidemment pour
d'en face
la réponse est un bouge mehdi chirac à
bulles de la mesure où le sait laurent
gbagbo et vient avec son aura de matis
il ya toutes les victimes étaient
battues autour de sa personne en bambou
tous les véhicules à face à free claude
à dabo devrait survécu au bord du désert
à pousser laurent gbagbo vers la science
et de la cpi le bateau tous les jouets
elle est incomplète elle l'assuré il est
bien avec paula pour son quart seulement
ceux du pbd est là pour le faire en
phase bien évidemment je pense que sa
double les calculs laurent gbagbo une
nouvelle fois président de la côte
d'ivoire c'est quelque chose qui est
imaginable aujourd'hui
bon cette image n'a pas besoin de plus
de 190 ce que raboter la présence et la
côte d'ivoire
ça a été par le fait l'alliance des
formations de l'information à savoir le
prix du blé
je vais laisser libres les modalités et
des lumières ehtp dû les alarmer
ouattara à partir du moment où le pdc du
métal et connaître les aspects d'une
balle dans l'eau en série d'un pacte
selon lequel celui qui est arrivé à
toiser en soutiendrait ce groupe 2 1
comme cela s'est passé en 2010 où le
belize et a soutenu d'inde annuelle a
tué m a cependant changé c'est qu'il
n'est pas exclu
il vous reste évidemment remporter la
présidentielle mais on est encore loin
des lifebook de compromis politique de
sorte à ce que je l'appelle a été
condamné en 2002 à 11 ans de prison
merci beaucoup silva n'guessan d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes analyste politique ivoirien